bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors faut-il selon vous déclarer
l'état d'urgence sanitaire en france est
donc donné la possibilité pour le
premier ministre de pouvoir légiférer
par décrets bah écoutez je crains qu'ils
ne le fail mais sauf que il le faut
parce que rien n'a été fait en amont
en réalité cette loi est un peu logique
dans le contexte de désastre sanitaire
qui résulte du trop peu trop tard qui a
caractérisé l'action du gouvernement
jusqu'à ces dernières jusqu'à ces
derniers jours
voilà donc aujourd'hui le gouvernement
en est à prendre des mesures d'urgence
précisément parce que il n'a pas su dès
le départ notamment par exemple et
rétablir des contrôles aux frontières
prévoir l'ampleur de cette de cette
pandémie
alors on oublie souvent que c'est comme
le h1n1 ou comme le strass pas du tout
puisque dès le départ la chine a confiné
50 millions de personnes ca net ça n'a
pas été le cas pour les deux virus que
je vienne cité donc dès le départ on
savait que compte tenu de ce qui se
passe rien de ce qui se passait en chine
de toute façon c'est un virus qui
n'avait qu'il était pareille à nulle
autre et que la propagation à aller se
faire et malgré ça on a laissé faire les
déclarations d'agnès busin récemment
rajoute encore à cette incertitude
disant que emmanuel macron pendant dix
jours était au courant de la catastrophe
mais qu'il a temporisé qu'il a pratiqué
l'attentisme parce qu'il se refusait à
arrêter l'appareil productif du pays
moyennant quoi maintenant évidemment on
est obligé d'agir dans l'urgence et il
faut prendre les mesures d'urgence qui
s'imposent à l'urgence qui découlent de
l'inaction initial ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que le gouvernement n'a pas
anticipé cette pandémie cette crise du
corona virus est notamment due aux
élections municipales qui on le rappelle
le second tour est reporté comment vous
vous l'accueillez vous au rassemblement
national will a créé le gouvernement n'a
certainement pas anticipé cette cette
crise on se rappelle quand même d'un
certain nombre de mesures brouillonne
qui relève d'un amateurisme assez
effarant par exemple lorsqu'on a laissé
le match lyon turin se dérouler à lyon
avec des milliers de supporters italiens
qui arrive est ce que c'est un hasard si
au jeu
puis la région lyonnaise est la
troisième région la plus touchée de
france est ce qu'on est en droit de se
poser la question de savoir si
effectivement ça découle
enfin en tout cas cette propagation du
virus dans la région lyonnaise ne
découle pas de cette irresponsabilité du
gouvernement voilà la frontière
italienne à ce jour n'est toujours pas
fermée nous adjurons le gouvernement de
fraude fermer la frontière avec l'italie
dont on sait que l'italie du nord et
l'un des foyers principaux de la
pandémie
le système de santé italien est
défaillant et croule sous les malades
donc il est à craindre un afflux de
malades italien verra le système de
santé français qui commencent déjà à
être saturé donc on voit bien solide
depuis le début et jusqu'à ce jour le
gouvernement est dans la et court après
le virus en quelque sorte il ne
l'anticipaient rien alors après sur la
loi de l'état d'urgence il faut aussi
que d'urgence sanitaire j'entends il
faut aussi qu'elle soit appliquée à tout
le territoire
on sait très bien qu'il ya des zones en
france les zones de non france
précisément les zones de non droit où on
l'a vu récemment il s'est tu le
confinement par exemple n'est pas
respectée alors dans ce projet de loi
d'urgence figurent également la
possibilité pour le gouvernement
prolongé par ordonnance les titres de
séjour c'est une mesure de bon sens
selon vous ben écoutez je m'étonne si
vous voulez que ce thème arrive dans le
projet de loi durant ce même s'il
s'agissait d'une priorité nationale
moi je pense qu'il faut surtout
maintenant s'intéresser à la santé et à
la protection de nos concitoyens les
encore une fois les nôtres avant les
autres que l'on parle effectivement de
mesures administratives etc
est-ce que ça doit figurer dans un
projet de loi d'état d'urgence sanitaire
qui est censé protéger la france et les
français
je ne le sais pas toujours est il qu'on
voit une fois moi je jeu j'adjure le
gouvernement de prendre les mesures
adéquates
aujourd'hui la france est un des pays au
monde qui n'a toujours pas fermé ses
frontières pourquoi pourquoi est ce que
dans certains quartiers on laisse encore
les gens se balader et la police
nationale n'a pas ordre d'appliquer si
vous voulez là les instructions du
gouvernement en matière de confinement
il faut par exemple songer à rétablir
l'opération sentinelles
pour qu'ils aient des renforts armés
dans les zones où ce confinement n'est
pas respectée il est temps que le
gouvernement prenne le taureau par les
cornes et sache enfin que la volonté
politique peut être infléchir sur le
réel
il a trop attendu et malgré le fait que
aujourd'hui le pays est dans une en état
d'urgence absolue
on sent quand même qu'il est toujours un
peu timoré à faire ce que son logiciel
idéologiques traditionnels l'empêchent
de faire c'est à dire agir
merci merci merci beaucoup jean messier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes membre du bureau
national du rassemblement national